microsoft is testing a way for you to
share game pass with the ones you love
most and blizzard isn't interested in
another overwatch beta
microsoft has begun testing an xbox game
pass family plan in two countries which
will allow users to share their
subscription with other people rumors of
a family plan surfaced earlier this year
and this test will determine how the
service can be applied to a wider range
of users colombian and irish testers
will need to sign up for an xbox
insider's preview account to take part
an existing time on a subscription will
be converted to a new plan based on the
monetary value of the old membership for
example a full month of ultimate will be
converted into 18 days of membership for
this plan according to microsoft's tyler
mitlider current prices for xbox game
pass comes in at 10 bucks for either the
pc or console version while the 15 xbox
game pass ultimate tier adds a number of
other expansive options for play now
this hasn't been fully confirmed but
let's say that the family plan is 25 a
month and you get three friends and your
lame little brother to join you that's
five dollars a person that's five
dollars for all of the games that game
pass offers
i really need to start making some
friends
those friends will probably also come in
handy for overwatch too blizzard has
confirmed that overwatch 2 will not
receive a third beta prior to the game's
launch this news comes via tweets from
overwatch commercial leader john spector
instead of running another beta the team
will be using feedback received from the
game's alpha and two public beta tests
to focus on quote launching the best
game possible on october 4th numerous
balance changes to the game's cast of
heroes came and went over the course of
overwatch 2's public betas significant
adjustments to supports like zenyatta
and mercy came as a result of player
feedback about how the role didn't feel
fun to play overwatch 2 will replace the
original overwatch upon release will be
free to play and won't include loot
boxes it will instead allow players to
purchase cosmetics directly and will
also introduce a battle pass into
blizzard's fps for the first time and
you know what would be kind of wild but
also kind of makes sense
a mario kart game with a battle pass and
since we're on the subject of plumbers
that like to race mario kart 8 deluxe
placeholder music files have been
discovered following the latest update
which could be hinting at the future
booster course past dlc circuits the
pre-fetch files were uncovered by
youtuber record reader but the findings
were posted to youtube by bl and it
seems that they correspond to music
tracks from classic mario kart games the
50-second video contains each of the 15
discovered music files but only the
first seconds of each track are played
this is because prefetch files are
designed to start the music quickly
until the full song plays in the
background the tracks possibly heading
to mk8d are london loop from mario kart
tour peach gardens from ds and boo lake
slash broken pier from game boy advance
just to name a few but okay it's friday
and you know what that means stay inside
ignore all calls from your friends and
play a little far cry 6 if you haven't
already because it's free all weekend on
pc and console and if you like it it's
on sale too so you really don't have
that much to lose but also
if you're a call of duty fan make sure
you're watching the call of duty league
championship this weekend especially on
sunday because infinity ward's going to
be there and they're going to be talking
about modern warfare 2 and giving some
more information and also you can win
beta codes sounds like a pretty sweet
deal to me
i'll see you tomorrow
wait i just said it's friday tom will
see you next week
later
you